hey guys my name is Jess it is the tenth
of februari today and this is your
regularly scheduled wednesday edition of
games but knees tell tales walking dead
michonne miniseries finally has a
release date and some pretty pictures
fede look at while the third season of
The Walking Dead will still be a ways
off the first episode of the upcoming
miniseries into deep will arrive on
februari 23 it will be playable on pc
mac ps4 xbox one ps3 and xbox 360 into
deep will come to iOS and Android on
februari 25 this is the first time
telltale series will focus on characters
from the mainland comic book narrative
the series follows michon who joins up
with heat and his crew on a ship called
the companion as they Scout the
survivors and supplies as you can
imagine it sounds like everything goes
to [ __ ] pretty quickly the second and
third installments will land in march
and april respectively and the series
will run you fifteen bucks Rockstar
Games has revealed the GTA Online's next
free valentine's day-themed update to be
my valentine update includes the albany
roosevelt bauer and albany roosevelt
cars and a whole lot of new sexy clothes
to get your characters in the mood for
the occasion on top of that you'll have
access to all of the Valentine's Day
clothes and masks from 2014's
Valentine's Day GTA online event the
Valentine's Day Massacre special the
update also includes a new couples think
adversary mode cold until death do us
part which will land on friday the
update will come to ps4 xbox one and pc
finally one of Sony's leading VR
developers has left the company after 17
years to pursue his own career in the
virtual reality market a bronya was the
head of London studio famous for
creating the eye toy and synced our game
branded and his team had made
high-profile games for sony dr such as
the deep and the london placed if those
don't mean anything to you then it might
help if i say the one with the shark and
the one with the shooting dudes behind
at a
part Rania told gamasutra it was a tough
decision opting to leave Sony adding
2016 is going to be the year of the ass
so it's the perfect time for me to take
the step into independent development
emergence of a new medium like beer
doesn't come along very often and they
really want to be a part of this new
world let me know down in that comment
section if you plan on getting a VR
device this year and head to game start
we've got stories about rocket League on
xbox one and minecraft next update that
is everything I happy today as always
let me know your thoughts and feelings
on today's stories and I will see you
again tomorrow